it's a space mission 25 years in the
making
[Music]
the launch of the james webb space
telescope the largest and most powerful
space observatory ever built is one for
the history books
as successor to the celebrated hubble
mission scientists say the technology
aboard the spacecraft promises answers
to questions we haven't even thought yet
of asking
in my dreams and my hopes
seeing signatures
in
planetary atmospheres away from our
solar system that could hint to the
presence of life would be one of the
most important discoveries ever
using an enormous gold-plated mirror six
and a half meters across and instruments
that operate in the infrared spectrum
the webb telescope seeks to lift the
veil on cosmic realms that in the past
were too distant or too cold for any
previous telescope to detect
webb is a marvel of human ingenuity made
possible through the dedicated efforts
of thousands of scientists and engineers
and the close partnerships between more
than a dozen countries
the politics of course are always there
but as a scientist which in a sense try
to rise above that and say what can we
achieve together as a common goal
scientifically and that's how we can
achieve so much more together
by by pooling our resources pulling our
expertise but always with one goal in
mind let's do the most challenging
things that are possible 20 seconds into
the flight the web launch was carried
out by the private space firm ariane
space atop an ariane 5 rocket specially
suited for this particular mission
indeed iron 5 has been chosen due to its
reliability its track record but also
its capacity its performance the very
specific volume we can accommodate under
the fairing so 20 years ago in the early
2000s it was decided that webb will be
launched by iron5
while celebrations are underway
following the successful launch of the
james webb space telescope it'll still
be a nail biting 30 days before it
reaches its orbit
now on its way to its orbit at a
location known as lagrange lagrange.2
some one and a half million kilometers
from earth webb is on course to redefine
astronomy
and begin to unfold the mysteries of our
universe
manuel rapalo al jazeera carew french
guiana